Musique intense
...
-Argentine, France, Etats-Unis,
Japon, Chine, Algérie, Uruguay,
Espagne, Danemark, Royaume-Uni,
Australie, Afrique, Indonésie...
Sur les cinq continents,
casqués de fleurs ou armés de pavés,
les libertaires sont sortis
de la nuit et ont allumé
des feux de joie.
Eux que l'on avait cru vaincus,
ils ont partout repris l'initiative,
déclenché
de vastes mouvements
insurrectionnels
et pris l'avantage dans la bataille
pour l'hégémonie culturelle.
Gagner des batailles n'est rien
si l'on ne gagne la guerre sociale.
Or, dans les années
qui suivent 1968,
les anarchistes vont découvrir
un nouveau péril,
non plus celui de disparaître,
mais celui de se fourvoyer.
Face à un système globalitaire
qui met en scène les apparences
de sa propre critique,
leurs slogans émancipateurs,
leurs riffs assassins
et leurs figures ont parfois fini
par être récupérés.
Pour faire avancer leurs idées,
les libertaires
ne vont plus avoir
d'autre choix,
du local à l'international,
que d'avancer masqués
et, par la guérilla
ou dans la mobilisation de masse,
en revenir à la propagande.
Et c'est ainsi que,
des faubourgs de Montevideo
au coeur de Londres
et du Chiapas rebelle
à Seattle insurgée,
l'anarchisme va inspirer,
sans dire son nom,
les nouvelles formes
de résistance,
et dans la postmodernité
se voulant la fin des temps,
relancer pour un tour au moins
la grande roue de notre histoire.
...
Que l'année 68 ait été
une répétition générale
ou une révolution manquée,
il n'en reste pas moins
qu'elle aura laissé
un goût d'inachevé
sur la langue des révolutionnaires.
Comment ne pas comprendre
que certains
soient déçus devant le spectacle
des populations
reprenant le travail ?
Face au retour des éternelles
polémiques entre organisations
qui se rejettent la faute
et entendent ramasser les mises,
pourquoi ne seraient-ils pas
alors écoeurés ?
Que faire ?
Alors que certains décident
de prendre la clé des champs
et rejoignent à la campagne
des communautés,
d'autres, par optimisme
ou par désespoir,
choisissent de rester
dans les villes afin d'essayer,
par un coup de force,
de précipiter les choses.
Musique de tension
...
Pour les anarchistes,
tout commence en réalité
en Uruguay en 1965,
quand Abraham Guillen,
ancien combattant
au sein d'une division anarchiste
en Espagne,
diplômé en sciences économiques,
qui a participé à toutes
les tentatives insurrectionnelles
de l'après-guerre,
publie son livre
"Stratégie de guérilla urbaine".
Pour comprendre la nouveauté
de son ouvrage,
il faut se souvenir
que depuis le triomphe
de la révolution cubaine,
en matière de lutte armée,
c'est la théorie de Che Guevara,
le foquisme,
qui a les faveurs
des révolutionnaires.
Les guérilleros doivent partir
dans les montagnes et la jungle
pour créer, avec les paysans
et les indigènes,
des foyers insurrectionnels.
Cette théorie, qui fut efficace
dans le contexte cubain,
doit à tout prix,
selon Abraham Guillen,
être repensée pour les pays
plus développés.
-"Dans une guerre révolutionnaire,
quand les masses urbaines
"sont plus importantes
que les masses rurales,
"le centre de la lutte doit
se situer dans les aires urbaines.
"Les grandes cités
"sont des forêts de ciment
où les artifices
"de la guerre de guérilla
peuvent être employés.
"L'heure est venue
où une minorité révolutionnaire
"peut mettre la masse en mouvement
"et permettre de surmonter
l'aliénation par la peur."
-La théorie de la guérilla urbaine
et de la propagande armée
vient de naître.
Et Abraham Guillen de préciser...
Propos en espagnol
...
-L'objectif, selon moi,
c'est la prise de conscience,
la prise de conscience
que le système capitaliste
est fragile,
et que les prolétaires
peuvent donc mener eux-mêmes
la lutte armée.
Entre parenthèses,
c'est la vision classique
des attentats anarchistes
depuis la fin du 19e siècle,
la propagande par le fait.
-La théorie d'Abraham Guillen
se diffuse rapidement en Uruguay,
où la révolte gronde
depuis qu'en ce milieu des années 60
sévit une crise économique profonde.
Musique pesante
...
Elle inspire un groupe de jeunes
révolutionnaires, les Tupamaros.
Emmenés par Raul Sendic,
un partisan de l'autogestion,
fin connaisseur de Proudhon,
et rassemblés
autour de mots d'ordre libertaires,
on retrouve parmi eux
des socialistes révolutionnaires,
des communistes hétérodoxes,
des prêtres influencés
par la théologie de la libération,
mais aussi,
et depuis l'origine,
à l'image de Gerardo Gatti,
Jorge Zabalza et José Mujica,
de très nombreux libertaires.
-Les anarchistes participent
à la formation des Tupamaros.
Les Tupamaros ont d'ailleurs
un respect de la vie humaine.
En ce sens,
c'est une lutte très respectable.
-Les Tupamaros adoptent
la stratégie de la guérilla urbaine
et de la propagande armée.
Ils attaquent tous azimuts
et enchaînent les coups d'éclat.
Pas un jour
sans que leurs actions
ne fassent les gros titres
des journaux.
-Lundi : les Tupamaros
occupent une usine.
Mardi : hold-up
de 5 millions de pesos.
Mercredi : attentat à la bombe
dans plusieurs clubs politiques.
Jeudi :
occupation d'une usine et bombes.
Vendredi :
bombes et hold-up.
Samedi : dynamitage
d'une chaîne de télévision.
-Et dimanche,
en guise de repos,
évasion de dizaines de détenus.
...
Le pouvoir a beau dénoncer
leur violence,
les Tupamaros,
qui, d'abord,
évitent de verser le sang,
sont bien perçus
par la presse et l'opinion publique.
Ils bénéficient même,
à l'étranger,
d'une image positive,
comme le prouve
l'article que leur consacre
le Time Magazine,
qui les apparente
à des Robins des bois
des temps modernes.
Grâce à eux, la théorie
de la guérilla urbaine
et de la propagande armée
essaime dans le monde.
-Les gens apprennent
en répliquant.
Quand vous voyez un groupe
qui fait des choses,
que vous avez des connexions
avec ce groupe,
des réseaux se créent,
et alors,
on retrouve un peu partout
le même type d'action.
C'est ce qui s'est passé
avec les Angry Brigade.
-Partie d'Amérique latine,
la question
de la lutte armée
se pose en effet,
à partir de 1969,
à tous les révolutionnaires.
Partout, on publie des journaux,
on fait des films,
on écrit des livres
qui parlent d'elle
et des appels aux armes
sont lancés
à la télévision.
-Dans tous les quartiers,
sur nos lieux de travail,
nous devons préparer
la lutte armée
pour la destruction
de tous les capitalismes.
-Aujourd'hui,
on se rappelle surtout
des Brigades rouges en Italie
et de la Fraction armée rouge
en Allemagne,
qui ne sont pas anarchistes.
Mais à l'époque,
ce sont les libertaires
qui prennent l'initiative.
Comme un symbole,
il y a les Tupamaros West-Berlin,
avec Michael Bommi Baumann,
qui sont les premiers
à faire trembler le vieux monde.
En Espagne,
le groupe
Primero de Mayo puis les commandos
autonomes anticapitalistes
font parler la poudre.
Les appels à construire
la guérilla
sont entendus en France aussi
où, dès l'année 1970,
le Groupe révolutionnaire numéro 2
organise à Grenoble
une semaine de la dynamite,
suivi par les Gari,
qui passent eux aussi à l'attaque.
Ils enchaînent les hold-up
et multiplient les attentats
et les sabotages
dans tout le pays.
Même aux Etats-Unis d'Amérique,
d'anciens hippies
prennent les armes.
Le Weather Underground,
qui a la mémoire longue,
fait par exemple sauter
la statue des policiers
de Haymarket Square à Chicago.
Mais c'est sans doute
au Royaume-Uni
que la stratégie
de la propagande armée anarchiste
est menée de la manière
la plus emblématique
par la Angry Brigade,
la Brigade de la Colère,
une organisation qui n'a pas encore
révélé tous ses mystères.
-De nombreuses questions demeurent,
que les journaux
comme le Time et d'autres
se posent déjà à l'époque :
qui sont les Angry Brigade ?
Et eux, ils répondaient :
"La Angry Brigade,
ça peut être n'importe qui.
"c'est cette personne qui est assise
à côté de toi dans le métro
"et qui a de la haine
plein la tête
"et un revolver dans son blouson."
N'importe qui peut être
de la Angry Brigade.
Les noms ne comptent pas.
-Ce qui est très intéressant,
et qu'on a aujourd'hui oublié,
avec les membres
de la soi-disant Angry Brigade,
c'est qu'ils étaient aussi impliqués
dans beaucoup d'activités
d'entraide entre communautés
avec les syndicats.
C'était des poètes et des écrivains,
mais ils ont été décrits
par la presse de l'époque
comme une horde de terroristes.
C'est en réalité très loin
de ce qu'ils étaient.
-Ce collectif,
bien qu'hétéroclite,
n'en est pas moins
fortement mobilisé et politisé.
Décidé à passer
à la lutte armée,
ils adoptent ce nom
de "Brigade de la Colère"
et s'inventent un logo
où l'on voit
les signes masculin et féminin
s'entrelacer
autour d'une kalachnikov.
Car, à l'image des autres groupes
de lutte armée de l'époque,
ce qui déroute les observateurs,
c'est qu'on compte
de nombreuses combattantes.
Dans la lignée des pétroleuses
de la Commune,
ces femmes auxquelles
on attribue le surnom
"d'Amazones de la terreur"
effraient autant qu'elles fascinent.
On se souvient
en Allemagne de l'Ouest
de l'intrépide Nada,
du Mouvement du 2 juin,
et d'Ulrike Meinhof
de la Fraction armée rouge qui,
bien que n'ayant rien d'anarchiste,
était désignée comme telle
dans les tracts
mettant sa tête à prix.
Mais pour le public britannique,
c'est la figure d'Anna Mendelssohn,
que l'on soupçonne d'oeuvrer
au sein de la Angry Brigade,
qui synthétise tous les fantasmes
et retient l'attention
dans cette interview télévisée
où elle résume d'un mot
le sens de son combat.
Propos en anglais
...
-Sensibles aux formes de domination
et convaincus
que la meilleure défense,
c'est l'attaque,
pendant près de trois ans,
les femmes et les hommes
de la Angry Brigade
enchaînent les frappes.
S'ils ciblent bien sûr
les banques,
les sièges des grandes entreprises
et les centres d'intérêt
des dictatures,
ils élargissent le périmètre
des actions de la propagande armée
et lui ouvrent ainsi
de nouveaux fronts.
Musique pesante
...
-Certaines cibles
étaient inhabituelles.
Par exemple, ils ont fait exploser
une boutique de mode, Biba,
qui était pour eux un symbole
de la société de consommation,
et qu'à ce titre,
elle devait être brûlée.
-Pour bien se faire comprendre,
les actions symboliques
de la Angry Brigade
sont accompagnées
de communiqués explicatifs.
-"Frères et soeurs,
quels sont vos désirs réels ?
"Aller au drugstore
pour vous asseoir
"avec l'air distant, vide, ennuyé,
en buvant un café sans goût ?
"Ou bien alors le faire sauter
ou le faire brûler ?
"La seule chose à faire
avec ces maisons d'esclavage moderne
"appelées boutiques,
c'est les démolir.
"Le capitalisme, le profit,
l'inhumanité ne se réforment pas.
"Il faut les frapper
jusqu'à les détruire.
"Révolution."
-La logique, c'est de s'adresser
à un public qui va comprendre
les raisons pour lesquelles
vous menez vos actions.
Mais le risque, évidemment,
c'est que vous allez aussi
laisser de côté
tous ceux qui ne ressentent pas
de colère
et ne peuvent pas comprendre
la symbolique de vos actions.
-Contrairement
aux groupes de lutte armée
appartenant à d'autres tendances
révolutionnaires
comme les Brigades rouges,
la Fraction armée rouge
ou Action directe
qui ont pratiqué des exécutions,
et alors qu'ils envoient
des lettres piégées
aux journaux conservateurs,
aux grands industriels
et aux ministres,
afin de ne pas se couper
de la population,
les guérilleros urbains
de la Angry Brigade
s'efforceront toujours
de ne pas faire couler le sang.
-Ils n'ont jamais tué personne.
Ils ont fait quelques blessures,
mais pas très sérieuses.
-La propagande par le fait
devait toujours être symbolique.
Les Angry Brigade avaient ce slogan
très important, je crois :
"Seuls les fascistes
attaquent le peuple."
En anglais
...
-Et Anna Mendelssohn
de confirmer...
...
-Et pourtant,
comme au 19e siècle,
la peur s'empare
des cercles dirigeants.
On déploie un formidable arsenal,
on vote des lois,
on crée des unités spéciales
comme la Bomb Squad au Royaume-Uni.
Grâce à la toute nouvelle
informatique,
on met en fiche les populations.
En Europe et dans le monde,
la chasse aux guérilleros urbains
est donnée.
En Uruguay, par exemple,
le pouvoir se rigidifie
et multiplie les actions
de contre-insurrection.
Des actions sont lancées
pour arrêter
les figures
du mouvement Tupamaros,
comme ici Jorge Zabalza.
L'usage de la torture se généralise
et les escadrons de la mort
sont lâchés
aux trousses des révolutionnaires.
Cette répression a des répliques,
et fait, elle, en revanche,
des victimes.
Musique de tension
En Allemagne de l'Ouest,
le combattant anarchiste
Georg von Rauch,
l'un des fondateurs
des Tupamaros West-Berlin,
est le premier guérillero urbain
tué par la police.
En Espagne, malgré les mobilisations
internationales,
le combattant libertaire
Salvador Puig i Antich
est exécuté au garrote vil
dans la prison Modelo de Barcelone.
Au Royaume-Uni,
quelques prétendus membres
de la Angry Brigade,
dont Anna Mendelssohn,
sont arrêtés.
On leur fait le plus long procès
de l'histoire britannique,
et bien qu'aucun
ne soit reconnu coupable
pour les bombes
ou les lettres piégées,
on en condamne certains
à de très lourdes peines de prison.
Les limites
de l'action clandestine
et de la propagande armée
sont atteintes.
Alors que les anarchistes
avaient été les premiers
à en faire l'apologie,
ce sont aussi des libertaires
qui commencent à en faire
très tôt la critique.
-C'est un problème de où, comment
et pourquoi on fait un attentat.
Si c'est pour paralyser
le capitalisme,
ça peut valoir la peine,
mais si c'est un attentat
seulement spectaculaire,
parce que l'attentat suppose
une profonde inégalité
entre ceux qui ont la capacité
et le savoir-faire des bombes,
et les gens du commun,
ceux qui vont au travail
et qui n'ont rien,
à part, bien sûr,
leur capacité de grève.
-Tout ça me semble donner
une espèce d'idéal héroïque
guerrier...
à des mouvements
qui peuvent peut-être remplacer
le lent travail ingrat
d'organisation,
de formation, de culture.
L'impatience révolutionnaire
fait qu'on imagine qu'on va frapper
l'ennemi au coeur
en mettant une bombinette
ici ou là,
mais qui, en vérité,
ont rarement réussi à déclencher
un quelconque mouvement social.
-Devant les caméras,
quelques jours
avant son incarcération,
Anna Mendelssohn admet
la relative inefficacité
de la seule stratégie
de l'attentat.
...
Musique pesante
-Nombreux sont les libertaires
qui vont alors préférer
à la propagande armée
la propagande tout court.
A la fin des années 70
et au début des années 80,
après cette période de forte
offensive révolutionnaire,
les anarchistes reprennent donc
leur bâton de pèlerin.
Tout en s'investissant
dans le mouvement punk
qui éclot alors,
en ouvrant des maisons d'édition
et des librairies,
en créant des fanzines,
des radios libres
comme Radio Libertaire
ou en participant
plus sagement aux mobilisations,
ceux-ci retournent
pour quelques années
dans l'ombre.
...
Avec la chute du mur de Berlin
et l'effondrement de l'URSS,
le capitalisme triomphe.
Il peut à loisir se globaliser
et entamer sa dernière mue.
Il renforce ses institutions
et généralise son offensive
contre les corps,
les cultures et les paysages.
Le monde devient
un marché unique et global
auquel rien ne doit échapper
et dans lequel tout est soumis
à ses lois.
"There is no alternative",
dit-on à ceux
qui osent s'interroger.
-Cette intensification
du vol des richesses
et des ressources
est le résultat
de ces nouvelles
stratégies globales,
et cela a une influence
sur l'anarchisme,
qui s'inspire d'ailleurs
de nombreux mouvements indigènes.
-Ils sont inspirés principalement
par les zapatistes au Mexique
car c'est en 1994
que les zapatistes
se font connaître au monde,
avec leur insurrection.
-Le 1er janvier 1994,
au crépuscule du matin,
une armée en guenilles et haillons
s'est levée.
Propos en espagnol
...
-Tout ça commence
d'une manière très intéressante,
parce qu'il y a la menace
de la violence,
mais on ne peut pas dire
qu'il y ait vraiment de violence.
-Que veulent-ils ?
Qui sont-ils, ces guérilleros
qui ne semblent pas appartenir
à la tradition libertaire ?
-L'EZLN vient d'une autre tradition,
qui est plutôt au départ
une tradition, on va dire...
marxiste, voire guévariste.
Cela dit,
c'est une organisation intelligente
et qui a su prendre en compte
à la fois le milieu dans lequel
elle s'est développée,
à savoir le Chiapas, qui est
une région fortement indigène,
et donc s'inspirer un petit peu
des pratiques,
des traditions de la région,
et en même temps, aller rechercher
aussi dans l'histoire du Mexique.
C'est pour ça
qu'ils se revendiquent aussi
de Zapata,
de ce mouvement paysan,
et ils revendiquent aussi
Ricardo Flores Magon
comme ce précurseur
de la révolution
et, en même temps, celui qui a amené
le slogan "Tierra y Libertad".
-A l'autre bout de ce pays
où toutes les contradictions
du capitalisme se donnent à voir,
alors que près de la moitié
de la population vit au-dessous
du seuil de pauvreté,
ici, le Coca-Cola est devenu
moins cher que l'eau.
Les économistes ont beau parler
de miracle mexicain,
les paysans indigènes
de l'Armée zapatiste
de libération nationale,
descendus des hauts plateaux
ou sortis de la jungle,
connaissent dans leur chair
les effets
de la globalisation néolibérale
et de toutes les formes
de domination.
Ils occupent
les centres de décision
car ils n'entendent plus
être dépossédés de leurs terres
et de leurs traditions et souhaitent
reprendre leurs affaires en main.
Mais ils ont beau écrire
sur les murs
leur programme, les commentateurs
se désintéressent du message,
et c'est sur le messager que
se tournent alors tous les regards :
le sous-commandant Marcos,
un ancien étudiant en philosophie
devenu guérillero
mais qui,
sous l'influence des Indiens,
a peu à peu reconsidéré ses idées
et ses stratégies pour adopter
une pensée plus libertaire.
Son grade, qui n'existe
dans aucune armée du monde,
- au Chiapas, selon la formule
"mandar obedeciendo",
c'est le peuple qui commande -
tout comme l'usage du passe-montagne
témoignent de cette évolution.
-Le passe-montagne, oui,
ça répond évidemment
au problème de la clandestinité.
Mais en même temps,
tous portent le passe-montagne.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont tous
à la fois soldats et responsables.
Ce qui signifie pour eux :
"Nous sommes tous
frères et soeurs
"et nous participons tous
à la lutte."
Propos en espagnol
...
-La véritable originalité
du mouvement zapatiste
dépasse les symboles
et les individualités.
Elle réside dans l'exemple
qu'il donne
d'un autre monde possible.
Car l'expérience, qui a commencé ici
à la suite de l'insurrection
et s'étend sur un territoire
de la dimension d'un pays, mobilise
plus de 250 000 personnes
et représente
l'une des plus importantes
expériences
d'auto-gouvernement collectif
de l'histoire moderne.
Sociétés coopératives,
assemblées de femmes,
conseils
de bon gouvernement,
abolition de l'argent
et des prisons, universités
autonomes, hôpitaux gratuits...
Sur ces terres si isolées
et si dures à la vie,
ces hommes et ces femmes
depuis toujours
humiliés et méprisés
s'efforcent en effet
de combiner
pratiques ancestrales
et innovations politiques
afin de redessiner
un monde à leur image.
-Ils utilisent des formes
d'organisations anarchistes
dans lesquelles on retrouve
des assemblées de parole
où les gens mandatent une personne
pour coordonner
les activités du groupe.
Mais elle ne fait que porter
la parole de ce groupe
et ne prend pas de décision
à sa place.
Ce qu'ils veulent,
c'est une société dans laquelle
tout le monde aura le même pouvoir
et le même bien-être,
sans qu'il y ait
une autorité au-dessus d'eux.
-Voilà, c'est ça.
Voilà ce qu'est l'anarchisme.
C'est pour cela qu'on utilise
le terme de contre-pouvoir.
L'anarchisme n'est pas
une stratégie anti-pouvoir,
c'est une stratégie
de contre-pouvoir :
décentraliser et redistribuer
le pouvoir.
-C'est pour ça que je considère
le mouvement zapatiste...
comme appartenant à la tradition
libertaire et anarchiste.
Mais eux, de manière très saine,
à mon avis,
se méfient
et refusent les étiquettes.
-La geste des zapatistes
redonne espoir
aux révolutionnaires
qui se coordonnent au sein
du jeune mouvement altermondialiste
et viennent au Chiapas
pour participer
aux assemblées régionales,
aux conférences internationales
et jusqu'aux rencontres
intergalactiques
organisées par l'EZLN.
-La grande réussite également
du Chiapas,
c'est d'avoir mis l'accent
sur l'international
et la mondialisation,
et donc permis à tout le monde
de se retrouver
dans la lutte des Indiens,
pour peu qu'on ne cloue pas le bec
aux Indiens.
On commence par les écouter
et ensuite les suivre,
et non pas les précéder
comme une avant-garde.
Et donc,
le mouvement zapatiste
a réussi son pari,
effectivement,
de fédérer tous les mouvements
révolutionnaires,
à commencer par les libertaires,
à cause de son horizontalité.
-C'était un exemple
d'une manière différente
de faire les choses.
Depuis la chute
de l'Union soviétique,
que l'on soit pour ou contre,
les gens se cherchaient
un nouveau modèle.
-Mais cet exemple
est considéré
comme une menace.
L'Etat envoie l'armée
et les propriétaires terriens
leurs milices qui tuent au hasard,
comme par exemple
lors du massacre d'Acteal,
où 45 personnes sont exécutées,
parmi lesquelles 18 enfants
et 4 femmes enceintes.
Plutôt que d'enchérir
dans la violence,
l'EZLN décide de marcher
sur Mexico sans armes,
afin de faire connaître
son message.
-La stratégie zapatiste
- occupation, sécession,
autogestion -
vient relancer
des expériences déjà en cours
ou en inspirer de nouvelles
un peu partout :
dans le centre des empires
contre les grands
projets inutiles
et leur monde,
comme à la ZAD
de Notre-Dame-des-Landes,
dans le berceau de la civilisation
occidentale, comme à Athènes
où le quartier d'Exarchia s'insurge
contre les politiques d'austérité,
ou au coeur même des combats,
comme au Rojava
où les Kurdes, pris en étau
entre les mercenaires de Daech
et les armées
du pouvoir autoritaire turc,
font tout à la fois la guerre
et la révolution.
Car, malgré leur diversité,
ces luttes se font bien
au nom d'un même idéal,
comme en témoignent
les messages de solidarité
que les combattants échangent
au plus fort des combats.
Mais au tournant du 3e millénaire,
on sent
que la réponse locale
apportée dans les pays du sud
est insuffisante,
et c'est donc au nord
que la globalisation néolibérale
va recevoir
sa première réponse globale.
C'est bien sous l'oeil des caméras
des chaînes d'info en continu
et au coeur
de la première puissance mondiale
que le 3e millénaire commence,
avec l'attaque d'un trade center.
Seulement,
pour l'histoire de l'anarchisme,
ce n'est pas celle de 2001
à New York,
mais celle
qui a lieu 2 ans auparavant,
tout aussi inattendue,
sur l'autre côte
des Etats-Unis d'Amérique.
-Je situerais, pour l'Amérique
du Nord, un point tournant,
c'est la rencontre de Seattle
en 1999,
la fameuse rencontre
de Seattle en 99.
-Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Moi-même, qui étais déjà
militant libertaire,
je l'ai pas vu venir.
-De manière totalement inattendue,
il y eu cette énorme manifestation
à Seattle
contre le capitalisme international
et aussi contre l'OMC.
-Qui a révélé soudain
qu'une nouvelle génération
d'anarchistes était présente
et qu'elle organisait
cette opposition à l'OMC
et à la Banque mondiale.
-Novembre 1999.
Au pied du mont Rainier,
un sommet
de l'Organisation Mondiale
du Commerce doit avoir lieu
qui entend rien moins que définir
les règles du prochain millénaire.
Déjà, on savoure
une nouvelle avancée du capitalisme
qui étendra son empire marchand
aux productions de l'esprit,
aux vivants et à tous les éléments.
Le président de l'OMC
et les gouvernants
des puissances économiques
n'ont pas choisi Seattle au hasard.
Ville natale de Bill Gates,
alors l'homme
le plus riche du monde,
la cité d'émeraude
est en effet
la capitale mondiale
de l'aéronautique commercial
et le centre
du logiciel informatique.
Elle accueille le siège social
de grandes compagnies
dont le nom rime déjà
avec globalisation néolibérale.
Mais c'était sans compter
sur la permanence ici
d'une longue tradition libertaire,
dont l'éclosion récente du grunge,
une fusion entre les mouvements
punk et hippie,
avec Nirvana
en tête de gondole,
qui aimait à parsemer ses clips
de A cerclés,
n'était que la dernière expression.
Sur l'appel international
à la mobilisation
lancé par tout un agglomérat
d'organisations, de collectifs
et d'individus
rassemblés au sein d'un mouvement
des mouvements qui a choisi
cette occasion
pour manifester son opposition
au nouvel ordre mondial.
-Il n'y a pas de leader.
C'est un mouvement horizontal
d'action directe
contre les multinationales.
Bref, il y a tous ces marqueurs.
Et si un grand nombre
de personnes impliquées
ne se considéraient pas
comme anarchistes,
il y avait tout de même
beaucoup d'anarchistes présents,
et c'était clairement
un mouvement anti-parti
et anti-institutionnel.
Et en ce sens, on peut dire
qu'il était anarchisant.
-Le 30 novembre au matin,
malgré le fait
que la Rainier sit-in
n'a jamais autant mérité son surnom,
l'ambiance est joyeuse
et taquine : on plaisante,
on chante, on interpelle
des participants
qui se rendent à la conférence.
On pousse aussi
pour essayer d'entrer.
Les autorités,
qui avaient sous-estimé l'ampleur
de la mobilisation, prennent peur :
on appelle l'armée en renfort
et la garde nationale intervient.
Ce que l'histoire populaire
a retenu
sous le nom
de "bataille de Seattle" commence.
Pour répondre aux violences
policières et défendre le cortège,
un petit groupe de manifestants
a décidé de répliquer.
Soudain, un black bloc
s'est formé.
-Là, il y a quelque chose
qui fait intégralement partie
aujourd'hui
de l'identité du mouvement,
cette composante des black blocs,
que nous ne connaissions pas,
en tout cas
en Europe occidentale,
et que nous avons vue surgir.
Et alors, d'où vient-elle ?
-Le black bloc
vient d'Allemagne de l'Ouest.
Dans les années 70,
il y avait les autonomes.
Certains se disaient anarchistes,
d'autres ne se réclamaient
d'aucun parti
et se disaient juste autonomes.
Ils ont inventé la technique
du black bloc en portant le casque,
le masque et en se protégeant
contre les violences policières
et les identifications.
Il faut dire qu'à l'époque,
en Allemagne de l'Ouest,
la répression était très dure,
et les lois antiterroristes,
très sévères.
-Si le black bloc,
qui désigne une stratégie
et non des individus,
existait déjà depuis longtemps,
c'est bien ici et ce jour-là
qu'il se fait connaître au monde.
Pendant plusieurs heures,
devant les caméras
des premières chaînes
d'info en continu,
les révolutionnaires qui l'adoptent
assument la confrontation
et revendiquent l'usage
de la violence.
-Violence, ça veut dire
pas contre les personnes,
ça veut dire
contre les choses.
Ce qui se casse,
c'est quand même des vitrines,
par exemple,
ou des caissiers automatiques.
-C'est une violence
qui est très largement symbolique,
qui n'est pas une violence physique
directe sur des personnes,
qui bien souvent consiste
en des affrontements avec la police
mais pas dans une violence extrême,
qui consiste
dans la destruction, éventuellement,
symbolique de la propriété :
casser des banques, etc.
-Loin d'être chaotique
et désordonnée,
l'action du black bloc
est en effet raisonnée
et réfléchie.
Et si, sur son passage,
les vitrines volent en éclats,
ce n'est pas seulement
pour exprimer la colère,
piller ou jouir du plaisir
de casser pour casser,
les cibles ne sont jamais
prises au hasard.
C'est pour montrer
qu'il est possible d'attaquer
les succursales du capitalisme,
et avec ce spectacle
d'une violence très télégénique,
fasciner les caméras.
Coup double, en quelque sorte.
A l'heure du tout-médiatique,
où une image sensationnelle
vaut mieux qu'un discours,
ce recours synecdochique
à la violence est en effet
une propagande à la fois par le fait
et par l'image.
-Ils considèrent qu'il faut aller
lutter contre le capitalisme,
et c'est pour cette lutte
qu'ils utilisent ces techniques.
C'est facile à lire :
les banques, c'est le fric,
le capitalisme financier actuel,
donc on attaque les banques,
même si on ne fait
qu'égratigner sa surface.
Mais au moins, ça attire
l'attention de tout le monde,
et seule la propagande
gouvernementale fait semblant
de ne pas comprendre
pourquoi on attaque les banques.
-A propagande,
propagande et demie.
Les chaînes d'info en continu
diffusent en boucle les images.
Mais à Seattle,
on a beau déclarer
l'état d'urgence,
imposer le couvre-feu
et autoriser à tirer
sur les semeurs de trouble,
le pouvoir a perdu l'initiative :
on préfère interrompre le sommet.
Grâce à la mobilisation
et à l'action inattendue
du black bloc,
la bataille de Seattle
est gagnée.
Musique haletante
...
-Etonnamment,
ça a été un succès.
-On a vu qu'il était possible
de faire reculer
le pouvoir et que l'autorité
ne pouvait pas se maintenir
avec seulement la police
dans la rue.
L'autorité était sapée
parce que c'est une question de foi.
-Et depuis lors,
il y a eu de telles manifestations
partout dans le monde,
à Gênes, Naples, Québec...
Ca a explosé partout
où les gens étaient en conflit
avec l'autorité.
-Dans les années suivantes,
sur tous les continents,
l'ombre du black bloc plane
sur les sommets qui se claquemurent
et se barricadent.
Il faut dire qu'à la suite
de Seattle,
son ombre n'a cessé
de grandir.
Sa présence devient
de plus en plus massive
dans les manifestations,
son action, rapide et efficace,
et ses images,
toujours plus fascinantes.
Le phénomène est tel qu'en 2012,
l'émeutier devient
le personnage de l'année
de Time Magazine.
Comme à la fin du 19e siècle,
dans les cercles du pouvoir,
on parle à nouveau
d'une internationale noire
et l'on met tout en oeuvre
pour que Seattle ne puisse plus
se reproduire.
-On s'est servi de Seattle
pour justifier des recherches
dans le domaine des nouvelles armes.
Aux Etats-Unis, par exemple,
il y a eu des recherches
sur des armes non létales
comme ils disent,
des ultrasons,
des lasers,
tout ce qui pourrait être utilisé
dans des manifestations
contre les manifestants.
Et on a commencé à voir la police
se comporter comme une armée.
Les forces de l'ordre
se sont en quelque sorte
militarisées un peu partout.
-Cet arsenal de maintien de l'ordre
est aussitôt mis à contribution.
Dans toutes les grandes
manifestations,
avec ces armes non létales,
on éborgne, mutile
et occasionnellement on tue,
comme c'est arrivé en France
avec Rémi Fraisse,
qui meurt soufflé par une grenade
pour n'avoir pas voulu
que l'on détruise un écosystème.
Mais quand on perd le contrôle,
on n'hésite pas à ressortir
les armes, les vraies,
comme en Grèce,
où Alexandros Grigoropoulos,
un enfant de 15 ans,
manifestant,
est assassiné par la police,
comme à Oaxaca, au Mexique,
où le journaliste anarchiste
Brad Will, qui filmait
la révolte des professeurs,
est tué par un sniper
sous l'oeil de sa caméra...
Coup de feu et cris
...ou comme à Gênes,
où Carlo Giuliani,
un jeune libertaire de 22 ans,
est abattu d'une balle dans la tête,
et pour se dégager,
la Jeep des carabiniers
passe et repasse sur son corps.
A la fin de la décennie,
nombre de libertaires
remettent en question
la stratégie du black bloc.
N'est-elle pas devenue
trop systématique
et donc prévisible,
au point de se retourner
contre les manifestants eux-mêmes ?
Après 10 ans
d'affrontements, il faut imaginer
de nouvelles formes de lutte.
Depuis quelques années,
un nouveau monde est né : Internet.
Il faut dire
que grâce à la révolution numérique
et aux facilités d'échanges
informatiques qu'elle induit,
on a assisté
à une augmentation sans précédent
dans l'histoire des flux financiers.
Ce nouvel eldorado
tourne les têtes
des multinationales
et des grands organismes bancaires,
qui misent de plus en plus gros,
sans aucun contrôle.
Une bulle financière se crée,
qui explose en 2008, symbolisée
par la chute de Lehman Brothers.
On assiste à la banqueroute
la plus importante de l'histoire.
Pour la première fois
depuis la crise de 1929,
en Occident,
des millions de personnes
sont jetées à la rue
du jour au lendemain
et des pays entiers sont ruinés.
Si des révoltes éparses
ont lieu,
c'est à l'automne 2011,
au travers
d'une mobilisation internationale,
que de manière inattendue
et sans toujours dire leur nom,
les anarchistes vont à nouveau
faire parler d'eux
avec le mouvement Occupy.
Cris des manifestants
-C'est pour cela
que ça a commencé à Wall Street,
parce que Wall Street
avait ruiné l'économie mondiale
avec des fraudes massives
pour lesquelles personne
ne sera jamais condamné,
ce qui montre d'ailleurs
la totale inefficacité des Etats
quand il s'agit de contrôler
le capitalisme international.
Aucune action sérieuse
n'a été prise en ce qui concerne
les responsables de ces gigantesques
dévastations économiques
pour lesquelles
des pays comme la Grèce,
l'Espagne et ailleurs
continuent de payer.
-Inspiré par les occupations
des places
lors des printemps arabes
et du mouvement
des Indignés en Espagne,
en organisant un gigantesque be-in
au pied du temple
de la finance internationale,
Occupy Wall Street
enchevêtre rassemblements
de protestations
et création
d'une zone autonome temporaire.
-Le mouvement
Occupy Wall Street,
qui n'est pas un mouvement
anarchiste à proprement parler,
est très fortement influencé
par des anarchistes.
D'ailleurs, beaucoup d'anarchistes
ont mis en place
l'architecture
de ce mouvement.
-Des gens comme David Graeber,
par exemple, un anarchiste américain
qui a beaucoup écrit
sur l'anthropologie.
-Et d'autres encore,
qui, sans se dire anarchistes,
le sont dans les faits.
-Parmi eux, il y a aussi Kalle Lasn,
un journaliste canadien,
fondateur de Adbusters et auteur
du très beau "Design Anarchy",
Tom Morello, le guitariste
de Rage Against the Machine,
qui est aussi un militant
très actif des IWW,
le grand syndicat anarchiste
nord-américain,
ou l'éternel Noam Chomsky,
qui vient y faire des conférences.
Mais si toutes les tendances
de l'anarchisme se retrouvent ici
et que toutes ces tactiques
sont déployées,
la mobilisation a aussi
la particularité d'agréger
de nombreuses personnalités
qui n'appartiennent pas
au mouvement libertaire
mais doivent se positionner
en fonction de lui.
Car ce n'est pas le moindre
des paradoxes de l'anarchisme,
au moment où ses pensées
et ses pratiques
se généralisent, que de se fondre
et de disparaître dans le mouvement.
-Il s'agit d'idées
et d'expériences
qui doivent avoir un sens
pour nos vies
et qui puissent apporter
des réponses à nos questions.
Le problème
pour l'anarchisme
n'est pas de se faire connaître
mais de nous offrir
une sorte de caisse à outils
pour les problèmes
de la vie quotidienne.
-Est-ce important
de se réclamer de l'anarchisme ?
Non, les anarchistes
ne se battent pas
pour un monde anarchiste,
heureusement.
Ils se battent pour un monde libre,
et la différence est cruciale.
-En venant
des quatre coins du monde,
les caméras des chaînes d'info
laissent voir,
non plus sur des théâtres lointains
ou au travers
d'une violence spectaculaire,
mais dans des scènes
de la vie quotidienne
et au coin de la rue,
ce que pourrait être une vie
sans les nombreuses formes
de domination
et d'exploitation,
car pendant plusieurs mois,
ici, on médite, on discute,
on rêve, on chante,
on aime,
on partage et on s'éduque.
On abolit comme toujours
les prisons, les polices,
l'argent et les frontières.
On imagine ensemble
d'autres mondes possibles
et on essaie
de les réaliser maintenant.
-Ils ont adopté des formes
d'organisation anarchistes :
des petits groupes
qui se coordonnent
et essayent de trouver le consensus
au travers de la démocratie directe
tout en se posant la question
de ce qu'il fallait faire
pour que le mouvement
continue d'avancer.
-Mais ces gens qui, sans violence,
s'obstinent à agir
comme s'ils étaient déjà libres
dérangent.
Dans l'urgence, des lois sont votées
et la répression s'abat.
Musique pesante
...
-Les autorités,
comme toujours,
ont essayé de stopper
le mouvement Occupy Wall Street.
Elles ont remis en vigueur
les lois contre le vagabondage
et toutes ces lois du 19e siècle.
Et puis la police a cherché
toutes les excuses
pour empêcher le mouvement.
Elle a parlé de trouble
à l'ordre public
ou d'assemblées illégales.
Elle disait
qu'il allait y avoir des émeutes.
Cris des manifestants
-Mais plus on réprime
et plus on censure,
plus le mouvement s'étend,
et grâce à ces images
qui se diffusent via Internet,
plus il croît,
se transforme
et se multiplie
dans l'espace et dans le temps.
On occupe à Londres,
Francfort,
devant le siège
de la Banque centrale européenne,
à Tokyo, Paris, Montréal, Séoul,
Rome, Hong Kong,
Melbourne ou Tel-Aviv,
dans plus de 1500 villes
de 82 pays différents.
Et au travers
de ces grandes mobilisations,
sans toujours dire leur nom,
les idées libertaires
se diffusent petit à petit
et imprègnent à nouveau
toute une partie
du mouvement social.
-Peu importe que vous soyez
pour ou contre l'anarchisme.
A l'intérieur
du mouvement anticapitaliste,
vous devrez vous définir
en fonction de lui
et vous devrez
rendre des comptes.
Votre pratique
et vos organisations
sont-elles vraiment démocratiques ?
Votre fonctionnement
est-il horizontal ? Ecoutez-vous ?
Etes-vous sensible aux différences
de genres, aux sexualités
et aux autres formes de diversité ?
En un mot,
êtes-vous plus humain ?
-L'anarchisme ne s'enseigne pas.
Ca ne s'apprend pas dans les livres,
les écoles et les conférences.
L'anarchisme,
ça se "contagie".
C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une transmission
qui n'est pas
de l'ordre de la didactique.
-Le mouvement libertaire
profite lui aussi
de cette nouvelle popularisation
de ses idées
et de ses pratiques,
comme l'a prouvé le succès
des rencontres internationales
de l'anarchisme,
qui eurent lieu en 2012
en Suisse, à Saint-Imier,
et cette vigueur neuve
tord le cou aux idées reçues
sur l'anarchisme.
Lui que l'on avait voulu
limiter à l'Occident
conquiert encore des territoires,
comme ici, le 1er mai 2019,
en Indonésie.
Lui qu'on qualifiait
de petit-bourgeois
touche à nouveau
les milieux les plus humbles.
Lui qu'on prétendait minoritaire
trouve un écho dans la jeunesse,
qui se dit ingouvernable.
Et lui que l'on avait
si souvent dit vaincu
prouve,
malgré toutes ses défaites,
qu'il est toujours vivant.
-Il y a eu des défaites
dans l'histoire de l'anarchisme,
aussi grandes que les aspirations
que ces gens portaient,
mais il y a une autre façon
de voir ça,
qui me semble plus intéressante,
plus juste,
plus respectueuse des faits,
c'est qu'à travers
ces grands moments d'échec réel,
- c'est vrai que la Commune a perdu,
qu'en Espagne, on a perdu -
il y a constamment eu
des victoires moins visibles,
moins spectaculaires,
mais qui sont présentes partout.
Mais il est tout de même remarquable
que ce que les anarchistes
ont pensé, senti, promu,
défendu depuis très longtemps,
est aujourd'hui présent
dans beaucoup d'éléments
de notre culture.
-L'anarchisme
a eu un rôle fondamental
dans le progrès des idées
et de l'humanité en général.
Mais l'anarchisme a toujours l'air
d'être là et de ne pas y être.
Les anarchistes semblent
être partout, et en même temps,
on se demande tout le temps :
"Mais où sont les anarchistes ?"
L'anarchisme ne disparaîtra jamais
parce qu'il appartient
à l'être humain.
Chaque fois que quelqu'un
se demandera pourquoi il faut obéir,
il y aura de l'anarchisme.
-Loin d'être achevée,
l'histoire de l'anarchisme
se poursuit donc.
Mais au terme de ses presque
deux siècles d'existence,
alors que des figures plus récentes
ont succédé aux anciennes,
que ses courants se sont multipliés,
que ses stratégies et ses tactiques
se sont diversifiées
et que de nouveaux défis
et de nouvelles menaces
sont apparus pour lui
comme pour l'humanité,
il semble que
le message d'espérance
qu'elle porte et que rappelait déjà
Louise Michel dans sa plaidoirie
soit resté le même
qu'au premier jour.
-"Nous sommes
"à une époque d'anxiété.
"Tout le monde cherche sa route.
"Nous dirons quand même :
"advienne que pourra !
"Que la liberté se fasse !
"Que l'égalité se fasse !
"Et nous serons heureux."
-CAR NOTRE SANG BLEU EST NOIR
NOTRE DRAPEAU ROUGE EST NOIR
NOTRE ETOILE JAUNE EST NOIRE
NOTRE VIE EN ROSE EST NOIRE
OUI NOTRE SANG BLEU EST NOIR
NOTRE DRAPEAU ROUGE EST NOIR
NOTRE ETOILE JAUNE EST NOIRE
NOTRE VIE EN ROSE EST NOIRE
"Black bloc", Achab
...
BLACK
ET ON FAIT BLOC
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA